cientos de miles de hectáreas de Olivos
secos diezmados Este es el triste
paisaje de la región de apolia en el
extremo sur de Italia el culpable la
shailela una bacteria que has terminado
más de 20 millones de Olivos en la
Península en los últimos seis años
obligando a las autoridades a talar la
mayoría de ellos En estos invernaderos
este grupo de investigadores está
estudiando la shailela están infectando
deliberadamente plantas sanas para
probar su resistencia a la bacteria
aquí tenemos
en la planta Posteriormente se
realizarán análisis y si la planta
desarrolla los síntomas de la enfermedad
encontraremos rápidamente una gran
cantidad de bacterias pero si la planta
es resistente aunque se infecten no
tendrá una concentración tan alta de
bacterias
aquí se estudian variedades de plantas
de olivo Los investigadores están
aprovechando la variabilidad genética de
estos árboles para realizar cruces y
crear nuevas variedades capaces de
combatir la bacteria
mira este es un caso prometedor ya un
año después de ser infectado este árbol
no muestra ningún síntoma evidente
suficiente para dar Esperanza a los
agricultores como quintino ha perdido
30.000 Olivos infectados en sus tierras
esa mañana participó en un programa de
plantación masiva lanzado por el
Ministerio de agricultura italiano con
dos variedades de Olivos resistentes a
la bacteria
la Industria Del olivo ha sido devastada
por la shailela durante años no tuvimos
aceitunas Así que nos fue imposible
hacer aceite pero tardará unos años se
necesitan al menos tres años para poder
cosechar aceitunas aquí
desde la llegada de la shailela a Italia
en 2013 Estas son las primeras
plantaciones de Olivos permitidas en las
zonas afectadas un rayo de Esperanza
tras una de las crisis más graves del
sector agrícola italiano en las últimas
dé